sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner die
berichte jetzt heute haben sehr herzlich
zuschauer im reichen sauberen stuttgart
kam es zu einer gewalt explosion die
fast alle sprachlos gemacht hat es
begann feuchtfröhlich es endete in
brutaler gewalt steine wurden
geschmissen geschäfte geplündert
polizisten gezielt angegriffen
ein randalierender mob dem die polizei
selbst zunächst als partyszene
bezeichnete wenn man sich die szenen
angeschaut hat wieder ein junger mann
einen polizist voll in den rücken
springt dann muss man sehen es hat mit
taten überhaupt nichts zu tun das sind
junge leute die gegen den staat
eingestellt sind gewalt gegen die
polizei auch in göttingen vor wenigen
tagen ein hochhaus unter corona
quarantäne bewohner dürfen die beamten
mit flaschen steinen und pyrotechnik an
die polizei erlebt angriffe aus allen
richtungen auch von hooligans und
neonazis täglich 200 fälle von gewalt
gegen polizistinnen und polizisten zählt
das bundeskriminalamt
wir haben seit langer zeit eigentlich
stetige zunahme der gewalt gegen
polizeibeamte ein wirkliches alarmsignal
für unseren rechtsstaat
cem özdemir ist bei uns hast du mir in
stuttgart liegt ihr wahlkreis sie waren
am sonntag da und haben sich die schäden
an geschaut haben sie inzwischen eben
eine erklärung für das was da passiert
ist keine einfache die man in einem satz
zusammenfassen kann das war sicherlich
ein hartes kriminelles milieu das jetzt
auch nicht zum ersten mal in erscheinung
getreten ist dann gab es aber auch viele
trittbrettfahrer über whatsapp gruppen
die das mobiltelefon sind neu dabei
telefoniert worden und fand das
irgendwie cool in anführungszeichen dass
wir leben von leuten die hart arbeiten
kaputt macht dass man auf polizisten los
geht mit vorsatz auch um ihn schaden
zuzufügen und gibt ja auch genug
verletzte
deshalb hoffe ich dass so viel wie
möglich täter zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden aber das alleine wird nicht
reichen wir müssen uns auch mit den
ursachen beschäftigen wie es passiert
dass uns jugendliche verloren gehen da
ist ist erstmal egal welcher herkunft
sie haben sind unsere jugendliche
stuttgart aus der umgebung misst darf
sich nicht wiederholen
sebastian fiedler ist bei uns chef des
bundes deutscher kriminalbeamter her
spiele-hersteller die polizei sprach
anfangs von party und eventszene andere
wollen vor allen dingen linke und
migranten da gesehen haben was einte die
die auf der straße waren und so
explodierte gute frage das werden die
ermittlungen vorwiegend jetzt uns
erstmal anschließend sagen müssen aber
was sie eint jedenfalls ist dass sie den
staat in gänze offensichtlich ablehnen
weil sie ja nun die staatlichen behörden
als feindbild begriffen haben
ich will aber ganz deutlich sagen dass
es weder stuttgarter phänomen ist noch
ein deutsches phänomen
wir haben jetzt in diesen letzten tagen
in brixton in london in den haag
in dijon einen ganzen stadtteil über
tage in nahezu in schutt und asche
gelegt gesehen das heißt wir haben in
europa die stabilisierungs elemente mit
denen uns intensiver auseinandersetzen
sollen dann ist all diese elemente dass
sie den staat als ganzes aber
insbesondere auch die polizei als
feindbild erkoren haben und sich auch in
den sozialen medien diesbezüglich
artikuliert wolfgang bosbach cdu
innenpolitiker bosbach die polizei
konnte zitat keine links politischen
religiösen oder überhaupt politische
motive erkennen
sehen sie die zu beginn gab es ja den
hinweis auf die linke szene der wurde
dann nicht wiederholt allerdings für
mich persönlich ist der hinweis auch die
partyszene etwas zu schlicht
also unter einer party die aus dem ruder
läuft weiß jetzt nicht wie man in
stuttgart bad feiert aber wieso nicht zu
hören da keine sturm haben damit dazu
also partys die aus dem ruder laufen das
ist zu viel alkohol ruhestörender lärm
und ähnlich ist wir haben ja hier
massive gewaltausbrüche gesehen alkohol
drogen
ja das wird jetzt als ursache
herangezogen ist mir aber auch etwas zu
einfach die bilder die wir hier gesehen
haben lasse ich auf eine enorme wut auf
diesen start schließen auf die
repräsentanten dieses staates die
polizei repräsentiert das staatliche
gewaltmonopol und das ist eine
demokratische eine zivilisatorische
errungenschaft ich ahne wie die
ermittlungsverfahren ausgehen werden ich
habe noch gut das ergebnis der kölner
silvesternacht in erinnerung ich kann
mir gut vorstellen dass die polizei sich
alle erdenkliche mühe geben will den
tätern habhaft zu werden sie müssen ja
jedem täter bestimmte taten zuordnen und
dann noch nachweisen können sonst kommt
das hier überhaupt nicht zu einer
anklage geschweige denn zu einer
verurteilung
und am ende war es sicherlich ein motiv
bündel und nicht nur ein einzelner
anlass idee bei da ist bei uns
kabarettistin bekannt als schauspielerin
und eine engagierte kämpferin nicht nur
für frauenrechte wenn sie auf diese
szenen schauen vorbei da würden sie
sagen da haben sich manche ein beispiel
nehmen wollen an den protesten die es
in den usa gab oder war es corona oder
wollte man irgendwie ein schickes video
produzieren und damit angeben ich finde
das faszinierend dass man erst mal diese
ganze globale bewegung black wife were
außer acht lässt und dass man das nicht
irgendwie mit einbezieht denn da geht es
genau darum polizeigewalt die anbieter
ossis oder schwarzen menschen vollzogen
wird und zwar regelmäßig systematisch
dass man das jetzt hier völlig vergisst
und ja herr busverkehr im recht das ist
historisch gewachsen
das ist nämlich das publizieren kommt
nämlich aus der kolonial kultur und es
diente dazu weiße menschen ihren besitz
zu schützen
also müssen wir noch mal nachfragen ob
das so eine tolle kultur ist die
deutsche praxis und ab jetzt mal was
anderes machen können aber ich denke
also erstmal natürlich wir verurteilen
hier alle am tisch unnötige gewalt also
die leben die kaputt gegangen sind sind
ja auch von migranten gewesen also
dürfen wir an der ganzen sache nicht
vergessen das ist eine generelle
staatsfeind schafft gibt finde ich
wirklich polemisch und übertrieben bis
zum gehtnichtmehr
was hier passiert das und es beobachte
ich weil ich habe jugendarbeit sehr sehr
lange gemacht berlin
ich habe an verschiedenen schulen
gearbeitet und ich habe sehr viele
momente erlebt wo wir auch
konfrontationen mit polizei hatten und
bei jugendlichen noch nie erlebt dass
sie ohne provoziert so werden oder in
irgendeiner weise schikaniert zu werden
einfach angreifen das habe ich noch
nicht erlebt ich nicht ich sage nicht
dass das sich gibt ich sage nur dass ich
das nicht erlebt doch das halte ich
nicht für ein typisches merkmal glauben
sie denn dass damit aber auch gewalt
gerechtfertigt wird von den jugendlichen
oder von den menschen die zu so gute
aller gewalt gegriffen haben ich sehe
das ähnlich wie die meisten glaube ich
am tisch das ist natürlich auch
eskaliert also da wird es schon eine
kerngruppe gegeben haben wir wissen
allerdings nicht viel und ich meine eine
sache ist natürlich auch klar wir haben
den polizeifunk gehört dass ich krieg'
ich übertreibe
jetzt sind nur [ __ ] glauben sie
ernsthaft dass ihn jemand der polizist
der so ran geht an migrantische
jugendliche auch nur an die hand respekt
erfährt also das sind heranwachsende
jugendliche auch wenn sie schon ein
bisschen älter sind
und sie sind nicht in der pflicht
irgendwie das vorbild zu sein sie müssen
es von uns lernen also respekt geht in
zwei richtungen und ich habe das sehr
oft erlebt dass jugendliche nicht
respektiert werden können von polizisten
also aus welchen gründen auch immer
stehen bleiben denn irgendwer in der tat
nicht sie machen ja hier opfer zu täter
sozusagen und verkehren ja die tatsachen
also sie erzählstrang läuft ja so die
polizei die jetzt ihr opfer von
gewalttaten geworden ist war auch noch
selber schuld so weit kommt es gerade
noch wir haben die rede die entwickeln
wie gesagt das habe ich auch nicht wie
sie haben gesagt dass sie provoziert
worden wo ich eine rechtmäßige und text
ich hätte nicht auch ich habe ich jetzt
nicht unterbrochen im gegensatz zu ihnen
sie haben auch etwas aus dem kontext
gerissen in dem sie gesagt hätte ich
hätte gesagt es gäbe eine generelle
staatsfeindliche das habe ich nicht
gesagt habe gesagt es gibt solche
gruppierungen und die gibt es nicht nur
in deutschland sondern auch in
europäischen staaten
aber hier geht es doch nun ist er ganz
klar die lage verteilt sie hat es eine
rechtmäßige drogenkontrolle gegeben
haben gibt es da irgendwelche kritik
daran
und dann haben sich ad hoc hunderte
solidarisiert mit straftätern die
übrigen die wir jetzt schon kennen auch
schon vorher bekannt gewesen sind als
straftäter und das auch nur eine sekunde
lagen zu rechtfertigen ist wirklich der
gipfel der interpretation dieser schritt
nichts cem özdemir nicht nur die afg
auch ihr parteifreund boris palmer will
überdurchschnittlich viele migranten
unter den krawallmachern entdeckt haben
bloß weil die beiden das sagen es ist
deshalb völlig falsch 5 40 prozent ist
ungefähr der anteil der menschen mit
migrationshintergrund wenn wir jetzt mal
zählt bei denen die da festgenommen
worden sind immer früchte vorgeführt
worden sind ist es ungefähr
repräsentativ was die zusammensetzung
die jugendlichen unter 18 jahren in
stuttgart entstehen also das ist
ungefähr so wie stuttgart sich
zusammensetzt und stuttgart war eine
vergangenheit nicht gerade bekannt dafür
dass es ein hotspot für kriminalität ist
im gegenteil wir sind parteiübergreifend
herum will der frühere oberbürgermeister
von stuttgart schuster von der cdu fritz
kuhn jetzt und seine mögliche
nachfolgerin gibt es ein breites
verständnis in stuttgart dass wir eine
weltoffene liberale stadt sind umso
erschrockener sind wir angesichts der
bilder und ich will zudem sagen was sie
gesagt haben
der polizei diese funkspruch ist ja
bekannt das kann man heute in der
zeitung lesen aber es ist die
stuttgarter polizei die das auf ab weil
da lege ich sehr viel wert darauf die
polizei hält sich da sehr klar erklärt
dass sie der sache nachgeht der
polizeibeamten festgestellt worden
das war die werden das jetzt intern
nachgehen das muss man auch machen
gerade weil es an die polizei zur echten
hohen anspruch gibt das ist die
visitenkarte unseres landes wir müssen
den rücken hinhalten unser job ist es
auch als politik uns vor unsere polizei
zu stellen weil die eben oft des kreuzes
hinhalten müssen für viele sachen weil
das so ist muss man natürlich auch
schauen dass bei der polizei es da keine
verfehlungen gibt das wird aufgearbeitet
bei uns erleben wird wie hat sich erste
mir auch sofort wieder nach ursachen
geforscht auch nach ökonomischen
ursachen zukunftsangst
arbeitsplatzverlust glauben sie dass das
verlierer waren die daten geprügelt wir
hatten auch gymnasiasten darunter die
sich da angeschlossen haben das ist ein
bisschen wie herr fiedler vorher gesagt
hat ich verstehe das ja jetzt wollen
alle quasi wenige tage danach die
perfekte erklärung die alles erklären
können es gab früher mal ein grundsatz
der deutschen politik und zwar
unabhängig ob es islamistisch
rechtsradikal linksradikal was auch
immer ist das man erstmal die polizei
ihre arbeit machen dass die sagen die
waren es die hammer das ist die analyse
und dann setzen wir uns hin und
unterhalten uns über die
schlussfolgerungen und da gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch streit gibt es
hoffentlich auch gemeinsamkeiten
das ist außer kraft gesetzt haben es
mittlerweile in echtzeit mit den bildern
zu tun
über soziale medien die afg insbesondere
gott wird dann hier glaube ich niemand
er hat dann sofort schon den täter und
wissen immer gleich die waren es nicht
oder die wand und dann arbeitet man sich
daran ab ich hätte gern wieder dieses
alte prinzip das heißt erst einmal
wir schauen uns genau an was passiert
ist wir sorgen dafür jetzt mit blick
aufs kommende wochenende da bin ich auch
in meinem wahlkreis in stuttgart das ist
nicht wiederholt heißt zu recht den
anspruch der bevölkerung der
ladenbesitzer dass wir die sicherheit
garantieren und dann ergreifen wir
maßnahmen dazu gehören strafen für die
täter
dazu gehört auch polizeiliche maßnahmen
stichwort licht ganz wichtig dass es
nicht im dunkeln dort ist das hat auch
als mit subjektiver sicherheit zu tun
dass sich fort kameraüberwachung wo
notwendig
stichwort natürlich auch alkoholverbot
vielleicht an festtagen am wochenende
auch darüber muss man offen reden und
dann geht es aber auch um die sozial
pädagogische komponente
ich will dass uns kein einziger
jugendlicher entgleitet in jeder
jugendliche sollte eine perspektive
darin sehen dass man durch eigene
anstrengung und durch hilfe der
gemeinschaft durch schule eine
ausbildung bekommt und die perspektive
in der gesellschaft hat und sich nicht
dass hinweg dröhnt und dann auf leute
zugeht die nichts dafür können wir
selber probleme hat alkoholverbot und
sperrstunde hilft das was herr fiedler
in ihren augen oben so ähnlich
ausschließlich das kann und muss man
hier alles machen genau in der
reihenfolge wir sind jetzt gerade jetzt
gesagt hat aber es greift meines
erachtens zu kurz weil es verkennt dass
es nicht nur diesen stuttgarter fall
gegeben aber wir haben situationen in
deutschland diskutieren wo einsätze
fingiert worden sind und aus den oberen
etagen mit handfesten dingen die
kollegen beschmissen worden sind ich
habe ihnen gerade ein paar andere szenen
beschrieben das heißt was ich eigentlich
erwarte ist dass alle demokratischen
parteien nicht nur worthülsen absondern
und die sind auch richtig und wichtig
sondern dass man auch wirklich merkt und
das bezieht im übrigen die
jugendorganisationen der parteien mit
ein dass hier wirklich alle
demokratischen kräfte sich einig sind
dass wir dass sie hinter den deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden stehen so und alle
übrigen diskussionen sollten nach einem
deutlichen absatz erfolgen das steht
erstmal oben und es hat folgt genau
diesen staatsverständnis wir das gerade
richtigerweise beschrieben hat ich
glaube nur es ist nicht allen
hinreichend klar dass wir eben
grundsätzliche gruppierungen so nenne
ich sie mal allgemein weil das im
prinzip auch nicht politische
gruppierungen sind die ich hier nur im
blick habe die uns nachhaltige probleme
bereiten und zwar über einen längeren
zeitraum
da sollten sie nicht die rollen
vertauscht werden seit wann muss man
eigentlich in der polizei daraus darauf
gefasst sein dass aus einem
routine vorgang im grunde genommen
plötzlich nicht so konfrontative
situation wird dass ich dann noch bildet
und die polizei mit einer solchen
situation konfrontiert stellen
spätestens seit sich die gesellschaft so
zu nehmen polarisiert hat das spiegelt
sich selbstverständlich wieder also wir
haben natürlich mit den teil der
gesellschaft zu tun die problematisch
sind die in ihren ansichten radikalere
thesen vertreten die außerhalb des
üblichen staatsgefüge sich gedanklich
bewegen mit denen haben wir es natürlich
zu tun und die polarisiert hat sich die
gesellschaften und deswegen auch der
blick nach europa weil wir dort
parallele entwicklungen verstellen sich
entwickelt jedenfalls zeitgleich werden
wir auch diese effekte verstellen und
das kommt teilweise aus zunächst einmal
in dem jeweiligen moment auch
überraschenden situationen weil sie
vielleicht man kann lange über diese
statistiken diskutieren die
interessieren mich einigermaßen wenig
sondern mich interessieren diese
handfesten situation über die wir reden
und das bedeutet natürlich dass sich in
der polizei diese debatten wiederfinden
weil sie sich fragen wie viel rückhalt
haben wir eigentlich steht die masse der
bevölkerung wirklich hier hinter uns wie
äußert sich die politik da wird genau
hingehört wer da was sagt vor den
spitzenpolitikern das kann ich ihnen
versichern und deswegen sollte man die
worte hier sehr sensibel abwägen und
wenn man hier zeitgleich diskussion
voraus den vereinigten staaten
abzusuchen der weise hier her trägt ohne
zu erkennen das sind welcher völlig
unterschiedlichen rechtlichen situation
sicherheitsarchitektur etwa 18.000
polizei wird nach zwölf wochen sind sie
in manchen bundesstaaten kopf absurd
diese vergleiche hierher zu tragen und
das auch noch in einem atemzug in einem
klumpert diskutieren zu wollen halte ich
für total fatale erstmal sollten wir
sagen so funktioniert hier der staat die
masse der parteien steht hier hinter
euch und dann diskutieren wir alles
vorbei da nochmal in die frage wenn
junge menschen ihren frust ihre wut
ihren zorn und auch ihre gewalttätigkeit
an der polizei aus lassen
treffen sie dann den richtigen
adressaten ist die polizei daran schuld
wissen sie menge haben sich entwickelt
also als ich in den 90ern noch ein
junges mädchen war da
zu den polizisten im türkischen abend ja
gesagt also onkel und onkel ist immer
etwas was auch mit respekt zu tun hatte
die war allerdings da war es allerdings
ein bisschen anders ich meine die
politik hat die polizei massiv
beschnitten also in allen mitteln
abgebaut abgebaut abgebaut wir haben
eine absolut überforderte polizei und
ich würde auch gar nicht sagen dass die
polizei an diesen missständen in
irgendeiner form die verantwortung trägt
die sind völlig überfordert
dann haben wir popkultur das heißt eine
krähe hackt der anderen kein auge aus
und was man hier einfach mal nicht
vergessen darf ist dass wir seit als
migranten ständig im visier sind ständig
kriminalisiert werden von allen seiten
und hanau dürfen wir an dieser stelle
mal gar nicht vergessen
sie sind alle außer gelb keine türken
sie wissen oder ausländer und migranten
sie wissen nicht wie sich das angefühlt
hat als das passiert ist sie sind
traumatisiert und ich denke das hat auch
eine rolle gespielt in dieser ganzen
sache der wir migranten wissen die
polizei schützt uns nicht wann ist der
respekt verloren gegangenes vertrauen
verloren gegangen
sie werden kein festes datum finden aber
in unserem land ändert sich viel alleine
der hinweis auf die anders kann man ist
ja nicht sagen ermordung von george
wright in den usa und dann sozusagen das
sprachbild ja bei uns in deutschland
darüber müssen wir diskutieren bei uns
ist genauso wie in den usa
das ist so etwas von abwegig aber es ist
klar wenn wir diese debatte führen dann
fühlt sich die polizei in eine ecke
gestellt und dann erwartet sie hilfe
übrigens nicht nur von der politik auch
von der gesellschaft da müsste
eigentlich selbstverständlich sein ist
aber nicht selbstverständlich in einer
solchen situation fallen wir der polizei
nicht in den rücken sondern wir stärken
ihnen den rücken nur zwei beispiele
jetzt garnicht touch kolumne schlimm
genug nach und stellen ein unternehmer
bietet hier gut gehen kann sind wir
hoffentlich nicht wenn ich sage wenn sie
einmal in den letzten jahren sowohl beim
bundeskriminalamt also man auch bei der
bundespolizei verfolgen das also nix
sagte gegenteil von stellenabbau
ein journalist der auch für die zeit
renommiertes medium beschleunigt
twittert noch vor der taz kolumne jetzt
ziemlich genau wortwörtlich in
minneapolis wird die polizei abgeschafft
inschallah hoffentlich bald auch bei uns
das ist der sound vor diesem hintergrund
erfolgen solche taten
das ist jetzt keine tragödie wie die 500
täter die bei der aus dem ruder
gelaufenen party zu werk waren aber das
zeigt was ich in unserem land verändern
vor wenigen tagen in stuttgart ein zug
kontrolliert kontrolliert einen
nigerianer hat kein fachausweis polizei
wird geholt so personen feststellung
sofort nachdem die polizei die papiere
überprüft hat bildet sich eine kleine
menschenmenge und beschimpft die polizei
weil es natürlich rassistisch ist wenn
weiße polizisten einen schwarzen
kontrollieren entstehen so oft fest dass
der papiere mit unterschiedlichen namen
hat und dann eskaliert das nicht so wie
auf dem schlossplatz aber es kommt zu
einer auseinandersetzung das heißt hier
wird ohne dass die betroffenen den
sachverhalt überhaupt kenne sofort
rassismus unterstellt gibt problem der
sicherheit in unserem land ist nicht die
polizei das problem ist kriminalität und
kriminelle
und ich weiß aus langjähriger erfahrung
in der innenpolitik die polizei selber
hat ein überragendes interesse daran
dass die schwarzen schafen aus ihren
reihen aussortiert wird die bewerbung in
deutschland für die polizei die dauert
länger als die ausbildung für die
polizei in den usa muss die hochschule
hat sich entschuldigung ich muss
eingreifen racial profiling ist
rassistisch und das wir ständig
kriminalisiert werden und mit kriminelle
migranten eigentlichen topf geworfen
werden mit kriminellen das läuft hier
schon eine ganze weile und das können
wir jetzt auch nicht mehr wegreden
jetzt müssen wir auch mal ehrlich
bleiben bei der ganzen geschichte
natürlich an migranten das gefühl wir
werden generell kriminalisiert weil es
racial profiling gibt und das kann nicht
sein
der europarat ruft deutschland
regelmäßig dazu auf war es gegen
rassismus zu tun wie viel respekt haben
sie vor dem europarat wer ist das für
sie dann ist das irgendwie muppet show
oder wer soll das sein warum wird darauf
nicht reagiert warum wird das nicht
ernst genommen warum wird es immer zur
seite geschoben warum versucht man
migranten und einer minderheit an
kriminellen dies natürlich in jeder
gesellschaft gesellschaftsgruppe gibt zu
zu kriminalisieren das ist mir
unerklärlich
wir haben mehr migranten in unis als
kriminelle würden sie denn sagen dass
wenn beispielsweise die polizei eine
shisha bar kontrolliert in der in
größenordnung arabisch stämmige männer
sitzen in der regel ist das dann schon
racial profiling in ihren augen
naja also dass wieder der polizei hin
nach ethnischen merkmalen also was ich
jetzt aus den pressetexten entnehmen
konnte es das ja erst mal schon mal
diese ganze klaren kriminalität
aufgebauscht wird werden mit falschen
zahlen dann doch lieber nochmal
einreihen
da wird mit namen indikator gearbeitet
das auch schon rassistisch ist also gibt
es ganz sehr schöne berichte von der
zeit die man sich auch da jetzt noch
angucken und an durchlesen kann
und das stimmt so einiges sich und das
sind polizisten die das sagen
selbst polizisten sagen hier läuft was
was nicht so ganz richtig ist werden bzw
bestreiten bestreiten sie
kleinkriminalität oder sagen sie es
werden nur die falschen unter verdacht
genommen
kleinkriminalität in bestimmten
deutschen großstädten in bestimmten
vierteln ist maßgeblich geprägt durch
arabische große vermögen oder
libanesische der finsternis schwedischen
volksgruppen und wenn jetzt gesagt wird
aber wenn man die in einem zusammenhang
stellt ist das sofort rassismus nein das
ist die erfahrung die tägliche
lebenserfahrung der polizei die
bundespolizei hat über acht jahre lang
geprüft vorwurf regel profiling und es
gab tatsächlich bei tausenden von
kontrollen genau 25 beschwerden und es
ist ja nicht so dass jetzt das war uns
ein zugbegleiter und nicht die polizei
habe das nur schwarze kontrolliert wäre
eine macht und ich kontrolliert also der
früchte
den tag an dem die polizei sagt den
kontrollieren wir besser nicht mehr gibt
es ärger und uns wird profiling wissen
sie dass polizeigewalt höchstens zwei
davon kommen vor gericht wissen sie das
eigentlich dass bei polizeigewalt bei
der ist so vertuscht wird
das ist nicht in ordnung
ich habe oder das müssen sie aber auch
ganz tolle machen ich finde nicht dass
es richtig ist zu sagen
setzen sie irgendwie kleinschmidt das
ist unsere erfahrung natürlich im wir
müssen ja gucken in welchen milieus
leben leben migranten ja also es sind ja
nicht diejenigen die wie philipp koops
frei und da kommt kein polizist
und dann hier sowieso ein fass aufmachen
möchte mir und wir fragen uns gleich
nochmal danach was die polizei da
eigentlich tut und ob sieben sich diesen
vorwurf gefallen lassen muss dass sie
tatsächlich ethisch unterscheidet und
unterschiedlich gegenüber migranten oder
menschen die eben einfach anders
aussehen als die mehrheit der deutschen
aber sind ja auch deutsche in großen
teilen dass sie da und er vorgeht also
wir haben jetzt die wahl des rückschnitt
artig heute haben zu machen oder
differenziert ich versuch's mal ein
bisschen differenziert ich finde erst
mal dass der vergleich mit der us
polizei und der deutschen polizei da bin
ich bei herrn fiedler falschen
vergleichen
wenn es dann anders ausbilden über jetzt
auch anders bezahlen ist auch wichtig
wegen korruptionsanfälligkeit und weil
der rückhalt der polizei in der
gesellschaft übrigens auch im vergleich
zu frankreich in deutschland ganz
anderes dass die akzeptanz der polizei
in der deutschen gesellschaft ist eine
sehr hohe und sehr viele untersucht
trotzdem gibt es allerdings ein problem
dass bestimmte milieus bei jugendlichen
zwar nicht nur mit migrationshintergrund
wie ein problem haben dass die polizei
als das andere
auf der anderen seite der barrikade
wahrgenommen wird es auch nicht übrigens
ein ganz neues phänomen
62 schwabing hat man das schon mal denkt
sie in berlin kreuzberg an die erste mai
demonstration die dann irgendwann ja
auch mal folkloristisch spuren wir jetzt
keine fußnote die tat seit 1990 auch die
polizei angefordert um geschützt zu
werden vor der autonomen szene also auch
das kann man den redakteuren der tat
zwar sagen dass die auch schon mal
dankbar waren dass die poliz
weil sie geschützt hat angesichts des
artikels und jedenfalls ich finde wir
haben uns als politiker weil die polizei
für uns oft schwierige sachen machen
muss für die gesellschaft vor die
polizei zu stellen wenn ich in minister
wäre würde ich sagen es ist ein privileg
die uniform dies ist unseres landes
tragen zu dürfen des kulturbundes wäre
das gilt für polizei aber weil ich das
sage und das ist wichtig jetzt da wäre
es schön wenn wir da einen konsens
hätten ist es umso wichtiger dass wir
denen die für uns dienst machen auch
sagen es kann nicht sein dass die
uniform unseres landes trägt
beispielsweise reis bürger bist also die
existenz des landes in frage stellst von
dem du dich auch noch bezahlen lässt
es kann nicht sein dass dubai
identitäten ist es kann nicht sein dass
du eine rechtsradikale gesinnung hat das
gebäude jetzt für islamisten und soweit
solchen leuten gehört die uniform
ausgezogen und zwar sofort damit polizei
kein schaden
jetzt muss ich los den brückenschlag
also es kam er das sind einzelfälle zu
sagen aber sind wir ein bisschen zu viel
einzelfällen deshalb verbrennt ein
flüchtling in einer zelle an händen
gefesselt wie geht so was
warum gibt es da keine schuldsprüche
oder nsu schauen sie da ist einer der
drei haupttäter
da kommt die polizei klingelt an der tür
soll durchsuchen
der gute mann steigt in sein fahrzeug
geht in die garage fährt weg und kommt
wie geht so was jetzt bin ich alt genug
dass ich nur so ein bisschen aus den
jugend schilderungen meiner dozenten von
früher weiß wie das damals bei der raf
war wie das land hart vorgehen kann man
darüber diskutieren wie man richtig aber
es ging hart vor
ich wünsche mir dieselbe härte im umgang
mit dem rechtsradikalismus ist einzige
was ich möchte
ich möchte dass unser staat
parteiübergreifend klar ist gegen jede
art von extremismus das ist da auch
einen konsens gibt da haben wir lange
gebrauchten der politik wenn wir ehrlich
sind nach dem regierungspräsidenten hat
sich was geändert weil alle gemerkt
haben es kann jeden von uns treffen ist
jetzt menschen hätte nicht sterben nur
hat muss früher in den garagenkomplex
nur halb richtig aber nicht das thema
das man da fehler gemacht dann ist
völlig klar
aber es ist nicht so dass die polizei
damals verdächtigen hat fahren lassen in
kenntnis des bombenfundes tat wurde
materialien mit denen man bomben bauen
können
den eindruck da aber davon gibt es eine
ganze menge verlieren müssen noch mal
ein bisschen sortieren ewig zu den
erkenntnissen kommen feindbild polizei
hat uns befasst die kolumne ist schon
erwähnt wurden letzte woche hat es in
der tat einen artikel gegeben
über die in deutschland bis heute
streitet ihr thema wohin mit polizisten
wenn man die polizei abschaffen würde
spontan fällt mir nur eine geeignete
option 1
die mülldeponie nicht als müllmenschen
mit schlüsseln zu häusern sondern auf
der halde wo sie wirklich nur von abfall
umgeben sind unter ihresgleichen fühlen
sie sich bestimmt auch selber am
wohlsten
cem özdemir ist das für sie satire oder
ss hate speech ist einfach widerlich so
da braucht gar kein vertun
dafür gibt es den presserat dafür gibt
es die klagen auch von
polizeigewerkschaft ist auch richtig so
da kann man im rechtsstaat was machen
das muss man sich auch nicht gefallen
lassen
ich finde nicht dass der innenminister
unbedingt die richtige instanz dafür ist
weil der innenminister muss sich da
natürlich auch die frage gefallen lassen
hat er es bei vergleichbaren fällen auch
gemacht in frankreich gibt es eine
anwältin die war nebenklägerin
vertreterin su verfahren aus einem
polizei computer raus ist ihre
privatadresse veröffentlicht worden wie
man mittlerweile weiß denn der meere
dienstaufsichtsbeschwerden und da hab
ich jetzt nicht gehört dass der
innenminister auch nicht klar gemacht
also wenn du das anfangs als
innenminister dann musst du jeden tag
fünf klagen machen deshalb auch da
bitteschön tu mal nicht so also bis der
alltag wäre es ist gut so dass die
redaktion des selber verurteilt hat es
ist gut so das ist ein konsens zur
demokratischen parteien gibt das wir so
nicht mit unserer deutschen polizei wir
fragen noch mal nach hause seehofer der
hat die anzeige heute am vormittag
zurückgezogen herr bosbach wir gar nicht
gestellt
gar nicht gestellt die idee
zurückgezogen so ist richtig es ist mal
ganz grundsätzlich gefragt die aufgabe
eines bundesinnenministers journalisten
anzuzeigen nein aber ich kann verstehen
dass sich der bundesinnenminister als
dienstherr seiner zwei polizeien des
bundes kommen
amtes und der bundespolizei bei solchen
widerlichen texten vor seine
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter stellt
das kann ich nicht nur verstehen ich
glaube dass das auch erwartet wird dass
ungeachtet hätte ich ihm nicht den rat
gegeben schreiben genau wie ich den rat
gegeben eine strafanzeige zu erstatten
weil er auch noch verfassungsminister es
sind schon viele strafanzeigen erstattet
worden und die rechtslage wird keine
andere durch die masse an strafanzeigen
zweitens damit hätte sich die ganze
geschichte umgedreht es wären nur noch
um die frage gegangen ob die
pressefreiheit in deutschland in gefahr
ist und drittens ich ahne wie das
ermittlungsverfahren ausgeht sie frau
beide haben einen offenen brief an die
bundeskanzlerin mit unterzeichnet in dem
sie herr jacobi fahrer sich mit ihr
solidarisieren solidarisieren sie sich
auch mit ihren text sagen sie das ist
satire alt sowie das ist ok ich muss
erstmal dazu sagen ich bin ein großer
fan von der arbeit von linguee ich finde
ihre arbeit großartig sie ist eine
brillante journalistin eine großartige
autorin und auf der so rum zu bashen
nachdem wir hier uns mit müll rhetorik
über migranten überzogen werden herrn
minister macht da gar nichts wenn ein
achtlos entsorgt werden soll
wenn man von krümmel händlern und
kameltreiber gehen dann postbus gehören
spricht wenn man von uns als genetischen
müll spricht wie das herr sarrazin
gemacht hat keiner ist er aufgestanden
und hat eine anzeige gemacht also
zumindest keine so seehofer und vereinen
seehofer entschuldigung jetzt muss ich
auch mal was sagen
bleiben wir doch bei der wahl es geht
doch nur um 1 es geht ihnen um das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz in berlin
sie haben kein sie wollen dieser die
soll sie wollen sich das nicht gefallen
lassen dass die polizei eigentlich
unterstützt wird und deshalb hätten sie
so rum und deshalb machen sie das das
hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun ob das
ein satirischer texas herr böhme man hat
mir auch nicht gefallen mit seiner asse
türken finden
sie fand ich auch nicht toll aber ich
stand 100 prozent bin weil hier satire
und kunstfreiheit und meinungsfreiheit
und pressefreiheit ist und das wird sich
auch nicht ändern aber bleiben wir jetzt
noch mal bei diesen text gewehr schwach
ist nach der einen stärkeren viel
heftiger beleidigen als der starke den
schwachen im prinzip gibt es natürlich
durch die asymmetrie
natürlich nur weil ich meine jetzt sogar
eins nicht vergessen das ist eine
journalistin
wir haben ja aber mit einem bewaffneten
staatsorganen zu tun ja und einem
organisierten staatsorgan ich finde da
muss man auch mal ein bisschen bis ein
bisschen beiseite lassen sie ist ein
satirischer text gewesen und ich sage
ihnen ganz ehrlich ich hab diesen text
ganz anders gelesen als sie ich habe
überhaupt nicht daran gedacht dass
irgendwie gegen die generell gegen die
polizei geht oder ob damit die polizei
gelöscht wurde
es ist ein satirischer text nur der
zeitpunkt an dieses an dem das
aufgenommen wurde von ihnen der ist doch
sehr interessant das ist nämlich genau
der zeitpunkt wo jetzt das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz in berlin
raus kommt woher seehofer ja schon rum
fiat hat dass er jetzt keine polizei
mehr nach berlin wird wie solide erste
single war ich heute wird er da die
polizei nicht zu seiner eigenen polizei
schicken will und dann aber einen
journalisten rausziehen
das sich lohnt sich heute übrigens dazu
können wir noch mit dem berliner
innensenator verständigt und geeinigt
darüber das ist doch der fall sein wird
und das ist also keinen dissens zwischen
der bundespolizei und berlin gibt
wenigstens soweit zu den fakten bleiben
noch bei dem text herr fiedler das
gesetz kollegen kollegen von ihnen haben
herr jacobi fahrer verklagt würden sie
sich anschließen wir haben das deswegen
nicht gemacht aus den gründen die
roßtaler aufgezählt hat ich hätte auch
das nicht geraten weil es diejenigen
waren die anderen beiden
polizeigewerkschaften weil sie im
wesentlichen dazu beigetragen hat dass
er noch mehr beachtung fand ich hatte
als ich ihn das erste mal gelesen hatte
mir gewünscht dass der text selber
möglichst schnell im mülleimer landet
und das ist nicht eingetreten weil eben
zunächst einmal viel zu viel beachtung
wird so ich hätte mir gewünscht es
fließt kein schreien um es auf den punkt
zu bringen
dass aber nun nicht eingetreten und dann
wenn man sich dann mit dem inhalt dann
moment befasst
bereich meine fantasie nicht aus um auch
nur an einer silbe irgendwo satire zu
erkennen er war aus meiner sicht einfach
hat den polizeibeamten die menschenwürde
abgesprochen im ergebnis und deswegen
halte ich in der tat für prüfenswert
dass die berichte sich mit der frage
auseinandersetzen ob ihr volksverhetzung
einschlägig ist so da nicht ganz
eindeutig und deswegen sind soweit in
ordnung jetzt gibt es inzwischen glaube
ich 25 anzeigen wenn ich das zum letzten
mal gelesen habe und sich gesagt wenn
ich finde ein punkt noch sagen ich finde
der umstand allerdings dass sich eben
jetzt viele solidarisieren oder dass das
viele überhaupt noch so intensiv darüber
diskutieren schließt ja an an die
debatten die wir zu beginn der sendung
gerade hatten das ist nämlich
gesellschaftliche kreise gibt die ganz
offensichtlich erstens keine satire
darin erkennen und zweitens bestimmte
botschaften auch noch besonders brillant
finden darin
und das sind genau die kräfte von denen
ich am anfang gesagt das ist außen halt
extrem gesellschaft kräfte die halt auf
die stabilisierung ausgelegt ist sind
parteien von links wie rechts und die
kriegen natürlich entsprechend das
futter und das führt im ergebnis dazu
dass wir in der gesellschaft hoch
schaukeln effekte haben die sich im
zweifel am ende des tages in welcher
facette auch immer das werden wir vorher
nicht erahnen auf der straße
wiederfinden
horst seehofer hatten den zusammenhang
hergestellt herr bosbach zwischen diesem
text und den krawallen in stuttgart
glauben sie dass die täter die taz lesen
ich habe gerade schon mal gesagt ist das
ist nicht monokausal es viele gründe zu
geben
aber beim kampf weiß das ja heute kampf
gegen rechts oder gegen rechte gewalt
oder gegen rechtsextremismus wird immer
wieder uns zu recht gesagt achtet auf
eure sprache aus der sprache werden
taten bei diesem thema habe ich diesen
satz noch nie gehört und deswegen ist es
doch wichtig dass wir kein
gesellschaftliches klima erzeugen oder
befeuern wo plötzlich die polizei der
übeltäter ist und nicht diejenigen die
sie zu bekämpfen haben nämlich
verhinderung und aufklärung von
straftaten dass die kernaufgabe der
polizei sie genießt in deutschland ein
überragendes ansehen über 80 prozent der
bevölkerung sind mit ihrer arbeit
zufrieden oder sehr zufrieden
die politiker wären wir froh wenn wir
eine solche zustimmungsrate
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass auch
die gesellschaft insgesamt unserer
polizei vertrauen entgegen kein blindes
vertrauen was schief läuft wird
aufgeklärt werden die konsequenzen
gezogen dienstrechtlich strafrechtlich
aber das wäre ein grundvertrauen
entgegen und das aus worten taten werden
können würden sie sagen horst seehofer
hat sich das immer auch in der
flüchtlingskrise beispielsweise zu
herzen genommen
ja ich glaube dass wir heute einen ganz
anderen umgang haben auch in der sprache
als zum höhepunkt der flüchtlingskrise
2015 2016
allerdings war in andere richtung auch
heute darf man viel offener über
objektive fehlentwicklungen bei der
zuwanderungspolitik reden als das noch
vor drei oder vier jahren der fall war
heute kann man auch ganz offen
fehlentwicklung ansprechen ohne dass man
sofort in die rechte ecke gestellt
werden das ergebnis der äußerungen von
bundesinnenminister dr
damit die überlegungen öffentlich
gemacht mit klagen oder nicht klagen das
hat auch erstmal dazu geführt dass die
debatte über diesen artikel die eher
kritisch geführt wurde auch in der taz
auch in dem milieu und das sehr wichtig
so wie sie sagen der wunder erst mal
wieder die reihen geschlossen das ist so
ich lasse mir einfach ein kopf es gibt
einfach zu viele leute in dieser
gesellschaft die vor allem damit
beschäftigt gräben aufzureißen wir haben
wirklich genug geben ich würde mir
wünschen geraden innenminister muss doch
die rolle haben gräben zuzuschütten
ich würde an seiner stelle in die taz
redaktion gehen und sagen lasst uns mal
diskutieren was ist euer polizei bild
und lasst uns mal gucken ob es da
irgendwie eine grundlage gibt ich habe
ja noch mal gesagt auch menschen die
sich als links definieren sind hier und
da glaube ich ganz glücklich wenn sie
von der polizei beschützt werden ich bin
jemand als grüner bekannt ich werde beim
einen öffentlichen auftritten durchs
bundeskriminalamt geschützt ich bin da
sehr dankbar dafür
weil ich mit rechtsradikalen zu tun habe
und mit türkischen nationalisten zu tun
haben das darf man ruhig sagen
dankbar ist aber ich sage nochmals
gerade weil ich dankbar bin ist es auch
wichtig dass wir darüber diskutieren was
ist die rolle der polizei
manchmal delegieren die polizeiaufgaben
die garantie ihre aufgabe sind die
polizei ist nicht zuständig für die
schulen polizei ist nicht zuständig für
sozialarbeit sie sich nicht zuständig
für wohnungspolitik also jeder muss
seinen job machen
damit alle in der gesellschaft das
gefühl haben dass ihr potenzial
ausschöpfen können und dass man das
nicht am besten macht indem man sachen
kurz und klein schlägt indem man sich
anstrengt und dann was erreicht in der
gesellschaft eine durchlässige
gesellschaft die rassismus die rote
karte zeigt dass wir meine vision von
der gemeinsamen gesellschaft